and welcome to a very special of  beginner breakdown it's bounty addition  to their rules yeah goodness that's the  only way you're gonna win what nice  truck hey Dennis hey Caleb what's going  on man other fee only kind of down  lately what's the real meaning of it all  why do we even play chess when there's  just hours and hours of mental torture  masquerading as a board game I've been  playing chess for years I just hit my  floor in classical I can't even I mean  think I'm getting worse at blitz chess I  just can't improve at all  why should I even go on that's I know  just what you need oh yeah what's that  challenge a small child to a blitz match  give him the chance to win some money  and then crush his dreams what a  wonderful idea  you